le wifi 7 va arriver des 2024 alors il
commence déjà à être implémenté dans du
matériel et on le voit ici sur le stand
de médiathèque au MW ça Bastogne
regardez wifi 7 gaming notebook alors on
aura exactement les mêmes bandes de
fréquence sur le wifi 6e c'est-à-dire du
2,4 GHz du 5 GHz et du 6 giga Hertz
alors on nous montre également sur un
smartphone de vivo compatible Wi-Fi 7 on
a bien évidemment les routeurs qui sont
là pour wifi 7 à la maison ça va
commencer ici bien par du matériel qui
commence à s'équiper doucement puis vous
allez voir on en est encore une fois de
plus au wifi si ceux qui veulent se
développer qui va s'intensifier et qui
va arriver davantage chez vous mais ce
que nous permettra de faire le wifi 7 et
bien c'est d'arriver avec des débits
encore un peu plus haut avoir des
connexions beaucoup plus rapides pour
une maison encore plus connectée puis on
se parle une fois de plus d'une
technologie qui va être déployée
totalement à l'horizon 2024 l'année
prochaine on y est pas encore et on le
voit ici sur le stand de médiathèque ça
commence à se mettre en place alors je
sais pas vous est-ce que vous avez du
wifi 6 à la maison est-ce que vous avez
du wifi 6e est-ce que vous avez déjà un
smartphone on peut difficile eux ils le
sont globalement pas tous donc ça
commence tout doucement arriver est-ce
que vous êtes sensible vraiment à cette
technologie ou pas du tout marquer le
moi bien évidemment dans les
commentaires